hey good morning that's right we're
standing about 50 yards in front of the
rented truck that police say was used to
deliberately plowed down people on a
busy bicycle path yesterday afternoon
now this crime scene it's still very
active in fact moments ago we saw
investigators in white suits a forensic
team arrived on the scene
to collect evidence the governor told us
this morning that they believe the
suspect acted alone there's no evidence
to suggest this attack was part of some
wider plot Jeff Glor is here with new
information this morning on this story
Jeff good morning good morning to you
according to our source Sipe off was
very pleased with the outcome of the
attack he said he wanted to keep driving
down that bike path and didn't mean to
run into the school bus investigators
also found knives inside the truck that
caused so much devastation the chaos and
damage stretch for about 14 blocks down
a bike path in lower Manhattan we were
really really terrified in shock of what
had happened and what we were watching
at the mind there was one female that I
saw in the body she must have seen it
actually happened because she just kept
screaming it's emergency responders
quickly swarm the scene loading the
injured onto stretchers one man on the
floor with EMS trying to help them and
then two other people who are covered
with sheets who appear to have bikes
next to them that look like they were
run over the suspect apparently drove
onto a path on the west side of
Manhattan and traveled around eight
tenths of a mile
striking bikers and pedestrians before
crashing into a school bus
he left the rental truck and ran through
traffic armed with two weapons that
police say were a pellet gun and a
paintball gun NYPD officer Ryan Nash was
one of the first on the scene he fired
on the suspect hitting him in the
abdomen and ending the attack the
suspect was arrested and taken to a
hospital more details are emerging on
the nationwide investigation in Florida
FBI agents visited an apartment complex
in Tampa that was listed as the suspects
last known address
in New Jersey a bomb squad searched the
suspects personal vehicle that a home
depot in Passaic where he allegedly
rented the truck before the attack in
Paterson police searched an address
where the suspect is believed to have
been recently living he lived here for
three months and obviously like you I've
asked a lot of people here no one knows
him that no one recognized his face
the accused worked as a driver for uber
he did pass the company's background
check and drove for the service for
about six months the company says it is
in touch with the FBI and nor it is
offering its assistance
all right Jeff thank you so much